ces élections provoquent une sorte de
déséquilibre cardiaque chez Marcel
Duguet autrement dit son cœur balance je
m'en passe québécois
j'aime bien la carte aussi parce que
avec le groupe
c'est la Ligue des aînés du mardi matin
dans ce salon de qui deincourt nous
sommes sur l'Île Perrot à l'ouest de
Montréal dans la circonscription de
Vaudreuil
normal libéral mais on sait jamais c'est
la troisième fois tout le temps la
bienvenue je pense c'est bon
elle c'est la candidate de la coalition
à venir Québec ancienne directrice du
Carrefour Jeunesse en emploi de la
région en 2014 il y avait à peu près 20
000 voix des corps entre les libéraux et
la CAQ alors qu'en 2018 autour de 2700
moi c'est vraiment le chiffre qui me
parle qui me dit que Vaudreuil veut du
changement et cette course à toutes les
chances de se résumer à un duel avec la
député sortante Marie-Claude Nicole
direction Brossard derrière cette
enseigne muscle et vitamines se cache un
quartier général libéral celui de Linda
Caron la présidente du parti bien
entendu l'objectif c'est de garder La
Pinière dans le giron du Parti libéral
du Québec et de succéder ainsi à Gaëtan
barette dans cette circonscription où
les électeurs ont un profil ethnique
très diversifié ce que je défendrai bec
et ongles toujours c'est la question de
l'inclusion mais là aussi candidat de la
CAC get une brèche dans la cuirasse
rouge
lors de l'élection partielle au
printemps dernier dans Marie-Victorin
Shirley dorismond de la CAC l'avait
emporté par un peu moins de 800 voix sur
pierre Nantel première victoire ici d'un
parti autre que le Parti québécois
depuis 1984 le candidat du PQ compte
aujourd'hui sur le retour des pékistes
égarées je suis un ancien test
et puis je vais il y a quelques années
j'ai essayé la quête je vais voter pour
le pratiquer québécois
ouais fermer des centres d'achats
quand j'entends je retourne au Parti
québécois ça vient beaucoup de gens qui
ont ressenti une fatigue référendaire
une fatigue relativement indépendance et
puis ces gens-là ont cru monsieur
Legault dans sa défense des intérêts du
Québec il essaie de les convaincre qu'il
n'aurait pas dû et puis il y a la
circonscription voisine de la porte là
encore la CAC menace le PLQ le Québec
solidaire y tente une autre sortie de
l'île de Montréal
c'est beaucoup de transport en commun
qui soit moins cher qu'il est
présentement celle qui veut prendre la
porte pour les solidaires était connu
comme la vétérinaire à vélo pour
l'environnement d'abord mais il y a
d'autres enjeux dans cette banlieue qui
n'est pas que cossu inflation et
logements parce que même si à
Saint-Lambert là on a la pression le
préjugé tout le monde est riche le tiers
de la population vit en appartement et
vit avec 50 000 dollars et moins par un
lien comme revenu familial ces quatre
circonscriptions de la montée régie sont
celles où les surprises sont probables
un abat est possible pour la CAQ tout
comme un coup à la Marcelle
ici Mathieu Prost Radio-Canada Montréal